hello everybody my name is nyan i'm the
black female engineer i provide
content for you and aspiring software
engineers and today we're going to talk
about
why i left finance and ended up
in software engineering and so we're
going to
go a few years back starting in
fall of 2016 i was set
to start my first year in college
i ended up being a finance major but
before that
i had to make a choice of what degree
i wanted to pursue and i had put
business
as my first choice for the school
that i wanted to attend you know the
college when you know
the whole establishment is the
university there's the different
colleges college of arts college
of music etc so i wanted to be in the
college
of business but that process of figuring
out if i was accepted into that specific
track and all
was going to take some time my business
school was
very competitive and so it would take a
hot minute to find out even if i was
accepted to the school
it was going to take a hot minute and so
in the meantime i had to enroll as some
type of student
because i was still accepted and i had
still signed on to be
a student of this university so i had to
pick a subject of course
and with me with the way i
wanted my college experience to go i
wanted to pick
a track that would afford me
a job right after college a
job that would pay a solid amount and
where i wouldn't have to
stress too much about money now
that being said if you're an underwater
basket weaving major don't come at me
there's
nothing wrong with that i love that if
that's what you want to do
i love that but for me i
went the more practical round i think it
has something to do with being
zimbabwean being
the child of zimbabwe parents i just
wanted to go that more practical round
and for me that left me with engineering
or business those were the two options
now i had already chosen this
but i didn't know if they had chosen me
yet and so
i signed on to attend my university
under the computer science route i
had signed on now before classes could
even start
i received notice that i got accepted
into this one over here
into the business school and so that's
where i
ended up that's where i wanted to go i
wanted to be in
business and so i was enthused and happy
and all of that
and so yes packed my bags went to school
now it's interesting looking back there
were very clear signs
that i should have gone either the
computer science or just the engineering
minded
route sign number one one of my
favorite classes specifically my
favorite class during freshman year of
college
was this class called mathematical
analysis in business that's
yeah i think that's what was math 11 12
mathematical analysis from business
and i loved this course this
course was made for me i would take it
again because
it was a course purely based off of
excel excel analysis and using data
points and inputs for business analysis
now excel people who really know it
professionally and can really code out
these crazy
spreadsheets it's a type of coding the
things you can do it can end up being a
type
of coding and at the time i had no idea
that that's what i was doing but i
was the person other people would go to
before exams to make sure that their
spreadsheets were up and running up and
good
because my spreadsheets y'all i i wish i
still had those my spreadsheets
the teacher can be like oh so billy bob
went to the market and got eight eggs
and then this and then this
and then the stock market went like this
and all i would need to do is and put
like
one of those numbers and then boom there
would
the entire array of answers be
right before me i was that committed to
excel spreadsheets and i loved it so
much
that critical thinking that problem
solving and just the act
of creating these calculations that
would produce
these answers i loved that so much that
should have been hit number one y'all
it wasn't it wasn't to me i think it was
just a further
hint that i was in the right place does
that make sense
so instead of it being the hint that i
was in the wrong place it was a hint
that was in the right place because
being a freshman you don't know what's
going on in these different majors you
don't know what you'd be doing and
as a job and all of that and so i was
like oh this is a class 4 business
i love this class so much i must be
right where i'm supposed
to be but then moving on to
work experience i ended up interning
after my freshman year of college at
elite garden six flags
and i was a finance intern for them now
i was very enthused to get this
internship
but did i decide that i wanted to go
back no
no i did not and this was the theme
for everything i did y'all like
this again should have been another hint
hit number two that was in the wrong
place
i kept on no matter how great the
company was no matter
how esteemed they were i kept on
rejecting the offer
to go back so my first job decided not
to go back
then after sophomore year i interned at
a big four accounting firm
did i go back no i was like nope i'm
good this is not for me
after junior year interned at bank of
america
merrill lynch and this is a top five
bank i worked in derivatives i loved my
team when it came to
accept the offer to join them after i
graduated full time
did i accept it no i just kept on
turning things
down because i was like oh i guess maybe
this specific route isn't it or i guess
this specific route isn't it
not that business wasn't it that thought
did not just never crossed my
mind as a student because what were my
options i
i am going to make this bread make this
coin
i need to get through this i'm not going
to be switching majors i'm not going to
be
delaying my graduation that was just not
an option for me you know
in my thinking i was like no that's
that's not an option for me that's not
the way to go i was
spearheading down this road but yeah
i just was like nope after trying
certain things after
applying certain places after interning
i'd be like no
no no no no so i mentioned bank of
america merrill lynch
so let's get back to that i
entered for bank of america merrill
lynch
summer of 2019 so this was the summer
after my junior year
and after this i would just have one
more year of college before i
called it wraps so summer
of 2019 i jet set to new york city
manhattan and i was working for the
derivatives team
at bank of america not gonna lie to
y'all i did not like my job
again i loved my team i loved this
company
my day today i did not like it now
hold up before any of y'all go into the
comments like oh you're just an intern
like of course you get you know clunk
cloak work no it wasn't even that
i didn't like my job i didn't like the
job
my co-workers were doing i i just didn't
like i didn't resonate with it i'm just
thinking
to myself like wow this is what i'd be
doing it just didn't mix well with me
until until the day
that pretty much changed everything my
manager
one day came to me and was like hey girl
hey girl hey youngblood um we would need
these journal entries put in updated and
all of that
they're for the month update our books
put them in
and call it a day i was like bet say no
more
and so i look at this project
i was like no i was like nah
so here's the thing it was not a hard
project
i think the fact that it wasn't a hard
project is
i think what deterred me so much and let
me explain why
it's not a hard project what truly truly
what it was
was copying and pasting about 300 times
that truly was what it was from one
spreadsheet to another
300 times from you know the information
they need
to the journal entry information they
need put it together
boom here it was going to take me
at least half the day all day because of
just the sheer
volume of everything so that's what i
was like no i'm not
no i'm not doing this like i would go
insane i'm not doing this
and so it was in that moment i was like
there has to be a better way what what
commercial is that
i can't if someone please comment below
please i beg you comment below
what commercial is that where it's like
there has to be a better way
and i started looking up ways to
automate things like this how to
just make it easier make the machine
work
for me and me not having to like maybe
some more leg work would have to be done
in the beginning but
the fact that this company's doing this
every month i was like
they will use this after i'm gone so
what what needs to be done
here to make that happen and so i spent
like the whole half day
from morning to mid afternoon that day
looking up and practicing and finding
ways to automate
this process and by the end of that work
day i had found a way to
do that and i remember reaching out to
my match i was like yo
come over here come come over here and i
just sit back and i press a button just
and everything got populated and
he was so impressed he even brought over
a different employee
it was like yo come over here look what
nya just did
and i did it i i sat back i said
everything was populated so i was
so happy they were so happy
i was so happy to this day
oh actually not to this day anymore
because now i'm working
so up till about three months ago
this had been the happiest i could do
not
this had been the happiest i had ever
been
at work i truly cannot think of another
time i've
ever felt this fulfilled this
happy this eager i i was walking
i remember calling i remember going to
the bathroom and calling my
mom immediately just so happy because i
had never
felt like this i had never like i was
gonna make me emotional
because i had never felt like this ever
y'all
and to finally have had a day
where i felt like i had made a
difference felt like i had contributed
in a way that
mattered and in a way that made me happy
because
it tapped into my problem-solving skills
tapped into
my curiosity and
allowed me to learn and grow
that was it for me all that was there
for me now that being said
y'all are gonna think i'm crazy for this
bro what i'm about to say
i still y'all i was like i said i was on
a very narrow road
everything else was black other than
that
path to get that degree i still didn't
get that sign
or take that as a sign of girl you need
to move fields you this this
finance is not for you you need to move
fields immediately
i still didn't realize it it still
didn't
click that coding and developing and
programming was what
i was supposed to be doing or what i was
supposed to be at least pursuing
and it's really wild thinking back
because i remember other
co-workers talking to me talking about
python programming
and how that helps with finance and
fintech
and i truly was so removed from that
conversation
i didn't even think about it in a thing
of me
the only explanation i have for it and i
hate to say it but it has to be said
or else there will be no change is that
i just never thought
that
i'm that person that
that is a career that
i was able i would be able to pursue i
just
certain things you put in your head as
okay well billy bob does this and
the jerry's of the world do this and the
ambers of the world do this like
certain things i think that's just how i
think certain things i
had just put in certain realms in
certain compartments and that
was also software engineering for me it
took such a long time
for me it's almost embarrassing to admit
but for me to even realize software
engineering was even a career path
because growing up i wasn't surrounded
by that
so it took a very long time for me to
even break open that
option of nonaiya you too
can be this person but anyway
even then when i automated this process
it still
did not click to me that yo girl
you should be trying to get into coding
so it actually
took about a year after that for
me to see oh my gosh i love this
and it was when this parent-teacher
conference hit
and now i had so much time on my hands
because all of my classes went past fail
and i was just i it's funny because i
can actually envision myself
literally in my bed just
just letting the hours go by and so one
day i was like nia girl you have been
given
the gift of time use it use
it and so i remembered i had one like
been interested in programming or not
and it's funny to even say that because
not interested in programming in the
sense of
oh i really liked math 11 12 i really
liked
automating this process for bank of
america let me try coding it wasn't even
like that
it was just a thing where you know
things pop up that everyone says to try
or everyone says to pursue
that's really where that came from and
coding is one of those things
and so i was like okay everyone says to
do this thing let me
try it so i tried it and literally
within
hours hours i was hooked i remember
that first week staying up till four
in the morning just trying to complete
coding projects and building static
sites and all of these things because i
just couldn't put it down
it had never felt like that in finance
i've never been like oh i just can't put
down these journal entries
let me just stay for one more hour
because i just love this so much
now if you do no shades no shade i'm
just saying
that was not me and so that is
when truly within just a few days when i
was like
yeah i i need to move i need to make a
switch i need
i need to make this happen and i was
just a few months away
from my graduation which was in may of
i was a few months away from that so i
couldn't just switch majors
and so i looked at all the different
things i could do ending up
with a coding boot camp now in terms of
the story here i have so many videos
as to coding boot camps and even
what i did during coding boot camp along
with
after coding boot camp to get a job so
i'm not going to go too deep into that
because i just don't want to repeat
myself but i'll link those videos below
and some will appear up here but yeah
decide to go to a coding
bootcamp and come the point where
i was supposed to start looking for jobs
i actually reached out to my manager
at bank of america from the previous
year it was like
hey i'm pursuing this new route
i would love to hear what your thoughts
are in terms of
job opportunities i loved bank of
america even though
i didn't like this specific realm of it
is there any track that you can
recommend for me is there any other
program you guys have
x y and z and he really tried his best
but unfortunately
all the programs they had for new
graduates and
new students or or just young people in
general
you needed a computer science degree and
this
is really where i first
started panicking thinking oh my gosh
am i going to get a job i don't have a
computer science degree
i have a finance degree but i don't have
a computer science one am i not going to
get a job because
of it and so that's really where i
started
to panic because of that now i want to
say you don't need a computer science
degree
to do this work some companies or some
programs
they do require it but you will find
many many
that don't but yeah i ended up moving on
from that
and now i work in commerce cloud
development so i'm very happy with
how all of this turned out i wanted to
provide you this
story to really give you more of a
complete look
into my journey those of you who have
followed me since the very early days
first of all i see you
thank you so much but you may have heard
snippets of this scattered
through different videos but yeah i just
wanted to provide
a space where it was everything just
put at once but now we're on the same
page
of my journey and i'm so excited to just
produce more content for you all
in terms of transitioning and being a
new developer being in this field and
yeah so please let me know in the
comments ways i can help you out please
and follow me on instagram at the black
female engineer i love
answering your questions i love just
talking to you to be completely
honest and so no reach out here
on instagram etc but i hope you enjoyed
this if you did
please subscribe hit that like button
and i'll see y'all
later bye